(fireworks exploding)
- [Reporter 1] Small
crowds in Eastern Ukraine's
breakaway regions
celebrated Russian President
Vladimir Putin's decision to recognize
their independence on Monday.
- To recognize these territories,
which are on Ukraine side of the border
as Russian territories
that gives him a pretext to send in troops
because the pro-Russian
authorities in these two areas
say that they feel like
they're under threat
from the Kiev government
and can Russia please protect them.
- [Reporter 1] Western authorities say
Russia has massed as many as
190,000 troops around Ukraine.
Now Putin has ordered what
he calls peacekeeping forces
to enter the breakaway regions
in response to what the Kremlin says
is aggression by Ukrainian forces.
Tanks were photographed
in the city of Donetsk
and witnesses said
Russian military vehicles
poured in early Tuesday.
Local authorities didn't immediately
confirm the arrival of Russian troops.
- (foreign language)
- This is a major escalation
because he's sending Russian troops
onto the territory of a sovereign country,
that is Ukraine.
It threatens to end the negotiations
that have been going on
for weeks now in Europe,
aimed at trying to get him to de-escalate
the situation at the border.
- [Reporter 1] Russia said
it's still open to diplomacy,
but Putin's move further complicated
those efforts to find a solution
and triggered a wave of
condemnation among world leaders.
- This is plainly in breach
of international law.
Russia should step back.
- [Reporter 1] Ukrainian
President Volodymyr Zelenskyy
discussed the crisis with President Biden
and addressed the nation.
- (foreign language)
- [Reporter 1] After Putin's announcement,
President Biden signed an executive order
that will prohibit US
investments and trade
in the breakaway regions.
- So this is not the
big salvo of sanctions
that the US and Europe
have been promising.
Those could still come.
It's limited, probably,
because they wanna hold
that stuff in their quiver.
If President Putin decides
to invade the rest of the country.
- [Reporter 1] The US Senates
allies have threatened
to unleash potentially crippling
sanctions against Russia.
Targeting its major
banks, state companies,
and key imports if it invades Ukraine.
- I think that we can expect
to see more efforts at
Hail Mary diplomacy.
But on the other hand, we could see
President Putin escalating further
and sending troops into the
rest of Ukraine and taking Kiev.
Or we could also see the
kind of cyber attacks
that the US Intelligence
and the US Government has been expecting.
- (foreign language)